let's get to the news former president Trump
held a rally on Saturday in Waco Texas near the
site of the Branch Davidian Cults compound
or as it's now known campaign headquarters
former president Trump held a
campaign rally on Saturday in
Waco Texas making him the first cult
leader ever to escape that City alive
during his rally on Saturday former president
Trump mocked Florida Governor Ron DeSantis and
said he has quote no personality which based
on the past makes him front-runner for VP
during his rally on Saturday in Texas
former president Trump dismissed claims
that he had an affair with adult film star
Stormy Daniels and mocked her appearance
you're mocking her appearance remember
that picture the two of you together
this looks like a picture you'd see on Facebook
with the caption last time seeing Grandpa
Russian president Russian President Vladimir
Putin announced over the weekend that Russia
has reached a deal with Belarus to station
nuclear weapons in its territory the deal
announcement came as a surprise both
to Nato and Belarus starting win
officials in Philadelphia announced yesterday that
tap water is safe to drink after a toxic spill in
the Delaware River that's right Philly residents
can drink water but they still can't pronounce it
water okay no go with water a fish is
a California recently responded after
a truck overturned and Spilled a load of
ten thousand empty wine bottles onto the
road they hadn't seen that many empty wine
bottles since week two of covid lockdown
an 80 year old woman in Canada recently received
the Guinness world record for most
blood donated said the woman I'm 26.
a high school principal in Florida
recently resigned after she received
criticism for showing students Michelangelo's
sculpture David which one parent allegedly
called pornographic and I can't believe I never
noticed this before but they might have a point
you never noticed that part because
you're looking at the tiny way
I took art history class that's
how I know what to call it
the TSA announced last week that it's
now classifying peanut butter as a
liquid so bad news now you're gonna have
to chug that at security too [Applause]
and finally New York City today launched
its curbside composting program or as rats
are calling it Restaurant Week President Biden
signed an executive order yesterday limiting the
government's ability to use commercial spyware
that could be used to hack citizens phones or
as he put it we're going back to landlines the
Manhattan grand jury investigating allegations
of foreign president Trump made illegal hush
money payments met yesterday without voting
on a criminal indictment okay in the words
of Stormy Daniels what is taking so long
look until we see that perp walk I'm just
gonna have to keep showing this one [Music]
when he does have his purp walk I
do hope they play that Brass Band
former president Trump was interviewed last
night by Fox News host Sean Hannity thanks for
having me back said Hannity and Trump at the same
time in a new interview with Fox News host Sean
Hannity former president Trump denied having an
affair with adult film star Stormy Daniels which
would actually be a better explanation for the
hush money don't tell anybody we didn't do it
been the same interview former president
Trump claimed that if Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis did not win the Republican
gubernatorial Primary in 2018 he would be
working in a pizza parlor why do I feel like
the only jobs Trump knows are ones from porn
if I didn't endorse Ron right now he would
be working as either a plumber or a stepson
Trump also said last night that he
has tapes of the FBI raid on his
Mar-A-Lago residence but he did
have to record over some stuff
oh awesome some a sympathy for Eric tonight
noted noted President Biden called on Congress
yesterday to pass an assault weapons ban which
is sort of like calling on McDonald's to make
you a Whopper they could do it they just
won't former vice president Mike Pence is
set tomorrow to travel to Iowa which I think is
actually the name of a color at Sherwin Williams
yeah North Dakota governor
North Dakota North Dakota governor Doug burgum
is reportedly considering running for president
and if you're wondering what his chances are
that ain't him and nobody noticed [Applause]
a vote for that guy though I got is not like
it seem like he likes to pass this country's on
authorities in California recently arrested a
man who allegedly burglarized several
Optometry offices Witnesses described
the subject as a person between four
and eight feet tall and very blurry
thank you they also they also thought that last
guy was Doug burgum finally today was national hot
tub day except in New York where the Jets don't
work and that you guys oh come on [Applause]
today at the White House Summit for democracy
the speech went so well we're even thinking
about trying it house Speaker Kevin McCarthy
sent President Biden a letter yesterday morning
and asked him to pick a date to continue
negotiations over raising the debt ceiling
because nothing conveys the desire to get
something done quickly like sending a letter
that's right house Speaker Kevin McCarthy sent
president buying a letter yesterday an outline
Republican demands for raising the debt ceiling
and for the greater good Hillary's agreed to it
not real don't worry president Bond told
reporters yesterday that he has already
used the full extent of his executive authority
to ban assault weapons and out of the Congress
quote has to act well I did win the Oscar
for Lincoln said George Santos [Laughter]
a bipartisan group of congressmen announced this
week that they will reintroduce the protection
from abusive passengers act which would ban
airline passengers who've been fined or convicted
of physical violence on flights and prison time
for anyone who takes off their shoes and socks
according to new report former first
lady Melania Trump likes living in
Mar-A-Lago because she's surrounded
by people who do not say bad things
about former president Trump okay but
word of advice don't go in the kitchen
see yesterday unveiled its new logo design for
North America and it's fine I
guess if that's all you have
Shoemaker I was like I'm not sure about that when
a Schumer is like that's an excellent joke about
Pepsi well that's what I guess that's about it
though like Pepsi's got a lower ceiling Honda has
issued a recall for more than 300 000 Vehicles
due to an issue with the side view mirrors
apparently what happened was all the objects in
the mirror are exactly as close as they appear
a dryer in Minnesota reportedly gave
a sheriff's deputy a get out of jail
free card from the board game Monopoly
along with his license during a recent
traffic stop but it didn't work and
he ended up getting his car towed
a Great Dane in Virginia recently gave birth
to 21 puppies over 27 hours of Labor though
when it was all said and done it turned out
she was a chihuahua [Laughter] [Applause]
that's right a Great Dane in Virginia
recently gave birth to 21 puppies well
she certainly knows a roll
over [Laughter] [Applause]
[Laughter]
ends according to a new study
Jacksonville Florida has the
worst drivers in the country
said drivers let me see that
and finally scientists believe they've found a new
source of water on the moon and Gwyneth Paltrow
already has it up on her site the Manhattan
grand jury investigating former president Trump's
alleged involvement in a hush money payment is
reportedly not expected to hear any more evidence
for the next month Oh you mean they need some time
off after hearing nothing but Trump's sex stories
please we just we just need a month according
to new reports several top Republican donors are
worried that Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
does not have the Charisma for a national
campaign this guy this guy doesn't have the
Charisma for a local ad campaign it looks
like a used car dealer who insists on being in
the commercials come on down to Ron's Motors uh
prices aren't woke and that's no joke Republican
Congressman Mike Gallagher warned this week that
China wants to use artificial intelligence to
perfect its quote orwellian surveillance State
unfortunately Republicans don't know what
that means because they banned that book
Dr Anthony fauci has reportedly sold his
Memoir for just under five million dollars
he will not narrate the audiobook though
because he knows no one ever listens to him
two fishermen who allegedly cheated
in a competitive fishing competition
in Ohio pleaded guilty this week to
criminal charges and face up to one
year in prison and do you know what they
do to people who cheated fishing in prison
because I don't I'm guessing it's literally
never happened before a travel companies
in NASA will offer the world's longest bus
Journey this summer which will take Riders on
a 56-day trip across Europe or for a cheaper
56 day trip book a Greyhound to Jacksonville
I feel like our one of our writers Brian did that
once and thought maybe the
whole audience had as well
it was announced yesterday that the sequel
to author John grisham's book The Firm will
be released later this year this news first
reported in an all caps text from your dad
today was baseball's opening day with all 30 MLB
teams playing games and it's about 40 degrees
here in New York so if you're the Mets this is
what it feels like to play in October [Laughter]
and finally the department store chain Macy's
announced yesterday that its CEO will retire next
year while TJ Maxx announced their CEO is just a
loose pile of pants and that that was a monologue
[Music]
thank you